aucun 9h et le quartier noir mais
maintenant c'est votre vision d'accor
maxime s'applique il doit peindre la
couverture d'un livre
il aime la peinture alors cet atelier
ludique pour s'initier aux livres pays
forcément ils adorent et son papa aussi
eux-mêmes sont demandeurs de ces
ajustements donc c'est très bien et
après avec l'école ils apprennent
justement à lire des livres en créole et
en mélangeant le français et le créole
non c'est très bien après la peinture de
la couverture d'un livre rénumérés place
à la lecture avec son auteur des
marmailles attentif à pari gagné pour
l'écrivaine sur la cata marines et mes
histoires c'est quelqu'un de très
maladroite
donc tout ce qu'il ya dans la cata mari
mais vraiment il y a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de livres à
sortir parce que je suis très maladroite
les autres livres on a par exemple
animaux bricolo qui est plus un conte
écologique avec de da brico récup
donc les enfants vont pouvoir faire un
peu de riz corée cuba aussi à des fiches
activités dans le livre qui vont les
amener à réfléchir avant de jeter
quelque chose en fait s'ils peuvent pas
en faire un jeu des livres édités
localement car l'objectif de cette
opération est bel et bien de mettre en
l'air le livre pays une filière en
grande difficulté selon cette éditrice
qui reste tout de même positive ou le
but aujourd'hui c'est vraiment de
faire des rencontres avec les auteurs
donc on a des auteurs jeunesse ado est
aussi adultes on a aussi des ateliers
pour les enfants et le but c'est qu'ils
découvrent le livre à travers autre
chose que ce soit la peinture la lecture
l'écriture
les bricolages aussi donc c'est vraiment
d'amener l'enfant à lire à travers à
travers la création
une opération qui se déroule au
lendemain de la journée mondiale du
livre et du droit d'auteur à laquelle il